Now that we've described the
displacement of our object--
remember that our displacement
vector delta r in this time
interval was x(t) plus
t minus x(t) i hat,
which we denoted
as delta x i hat.
Now, let's just remind ourselves
that this distance here, that's
delta x, and this whole
distance from here
over to there-- that's what
we mean by x(t) plus delta t.
And now what we'd
like to do is describe
what we call average velocity.
And our average velocity
depends on our time intervals.
So this is for the
time interval t
to t plus delta t
while the person has
displaced a certain
amount of vector delta r.
And our definition
for v average--
it's a vector quantity,
so we'll write v average--
will use three bars to
indicate a definition.
It is the displacement during
a time interval delta t.
So, as a vector, we have
delta x over delta t i hat.
And this component here is
what we call the component
of the average velocity.
So this is the component
And, again as before,
this component
can be positive, zero,
or negative depending
on the sine of delta x.
And the key point here
is that average velocity
depends on whatever time
interval you're referring to.
So that's our definition
of average velocity.
And now what we want
to do is consider
what happens in the limit
as delta t becomes smaller
and smaller and smaller.
And that will enable us
to introduce our concept
of instantaneous velocity.